but we begin with breaking news from
Britain one of America's closest allies
where the still new prime minister
announced just a short time ago that she
will step down after an uproar in
Parliament and an uproar in her own
party Liz trust she took over from Boris
Johnson just in early September she will
now be replaced in a new leadership
election the upheaval threatens to
undermine Britain's pivotal role in the
global economy not to mention NATO and
our Ramey inocencio has made his way to
10 Downing Street that's the prime
minister's headquarters in London raymie
good morning quite a whirlwind
that's why Liz choice is now the UK's
shortest serving prime minister
following months of political chaos and
growing uncertainty she will remain in
office as a lame duck Premiere here at
10 Downing Street until a successor is
named her resignation was widely rumored
but this announcement still came as a
shock
given the situation
by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
leader for just six weeks
a tale that started with a Hollywood
entrance on her first day as prime
minister she was a last Premier to meet
the queen but this story Twisted quickly
into a political horror show our
headlines
the Prime Minister fights for her job
after a chaotic day in the Commons the
deputy chief whip was reported to have
left the scene saying I'm absolutely
effing Furious I just don't effing care
anymore before he resigned
the tax cut loving conservative who
models herself on Margaret Thatcher
unveiled a massively criticized budget
of tax and spending cuts I will deliver
a bold plan to cut taxes that freak the
markets and sent the pound plunging
forcing her to fire her Finance Minister
and reverse those cuts 20 people tax cut
gone two-year energy freeze gone
tax-free shopping gone economic
credibility God
Mr Speaker
that I am sorry and that I have made
mistakes but her apology did little to
calm anger even in her own party I think
it's a shambles in a disgrace I think it
is utterly appalling the damage they
have done to our party is extraordinary
the trust tale stoked British humor with
this tabloid livestream of a head of
lettuce asking could trust last longer I
think um we're basically the Laughing
stuff of the entire world as per usual
but this is no laughing matter with the
finances and futures of nearly 70
million people at stake I'm 28 years old
the more of my future I'm worried for my
children
now the leader of the opposition labor
party is calling for a general election
and polls if true suggests that his
party would win in a landslide if that
happens soon but trust and the
conservative party are saying that they
will choose their own successor within
the week
all right to be continued Raymond
ascencio in London for us thank you Amy